you're a guy who's really working hard I
could see that you're putting out albums
at a pretty quick rate you're in a new
sort of genre of music for you it just
seems like you're on a roll and I was
thinking I wonder if people [ __ ] with
you all the time out of jealousy like do
guys come up and challenge you
physically do they [ __ ] with you
constantly all the time right yeah all
the time I even said to you the last
time I hope you have security because I
could see a lot of people be envious of
you it's its own plague it's very it's
it it it's sad it's almost like if you
just if you broke that wall down and
just talked with me you would have no
reason to have any of these feelings but
don't you want to say to them hey
[ __ ]
no one handed me anything I had [ __ ]
growing up my mind blows my mind even
even in even in the the genre that I'm
in when people act like this is like
some new thing or that I wasn't putting
like it's it blows my mind you can
literally look back 10 years ago at Rock
festivals and my name is right there on
the flyer like we've always been in the
culture I'm super confused where this
like oh he's new to the scene like [ __ ]
you right but we've we've been here so
for so long defying boxes and genres and
odds and like I saw somebody quote the
other day they were like um because
billboard came to do a piece and they
came to my house they quoted me saying
like you know you should give up your
comfort for this lifestyle as he sits in
his mansion with an infinity pool and
it's like dude I was [ __ ] Platinum
with two albums out still living on a
bean bag in my manager's apartment
and no they don't know that none of you
had [ __ ] to say about the comfort of
that like as if that didn't exist this
was after I had already had albums out
like this do you know how much that
mentally [ __ ] with you to be to have uh
where you can't walk down the street or
or take a piss in an airport or go order
a burger without people being like
aren't you aren't you weren't you and
like also maybe sometimes testing you
and being like you know what I didn't
like that you said that this or that you
do this and I'm I'm not even reaping
Financial benefits from it I'm just all
of my money is being taken from a puppet
master who is convincing me like oh I'm
here for you but I'm living in a [ __ ]
an apartment on a bean bag but meanwhile
it's like I'm about to put out a third
album
but somehow now that it like worked out
for me and I finally got my finances all
right that like oh oh man he doesn't
know [ __ ] about no Comfort no Comfort be
be happy for me because I'm happy for
you if I saw somebody
really take 10 years to finally get
their Moment by the time that moment
came I'm clapping I'm like wow I watched
you